I've been this idea of probability we're
trying to work out when events and
outcomes aren't certain I'm the
connection i want to draw was with
algebra where we look at numbers and you
don't know what they are here we're
looking infinite or outcomes and you
don't know whether they're going to
happen or not just know their charts
just need it properly okay so events or
outcomes these are just things that can
happen things that can home and we have
a very special name which we're going to
explore big once a day for the set of
all of the things that could have set of
all possible events all possible
outcomes anything that could actually
happen and we call it so remember starts
with an S all the events that could
possibly happen we call it the second
space okay so this should be this is
elevation for the people who here on
Wednesday right sample space is all
possible events or outcomes so that's
why you can see these two ideas relating
to each other click when you work here
at a probability you think about what
what are the events or outcomes that you
want but was it interested in and then
you divide that by the sheer business
it's how many possibilities behind so 4
is the probability of rolling United
like this of rolling an even number on a
diet right roll the dice how many
favorite weather events for outcomes on
it how many even numbers are there on
the day our top three and then you think
about the sample space all the possible
events of which there are six so this
probability is three out of six which of
course with writers a half because yeah
it's 5050 it's an even chance all these
words we export on website ok now this
idea of counting outcomes is that like
we can list these out like with the die
it's pretty easy 1 2 3 4 5 6 you can
have them on your head but if you have
something a little more complicated okay
so make a little sub heading for me
right for multi stage events this is the
summoning now again this is something we
reviewed on Wednesday a multi-stage
event as the
implies is an event and it's got more
than one part to it okay so you might be
playing a game where you have to flip a
coin more than once right so it's either
you win or you lose well that's an event
winning or losing but it has many parts
to it it's like I roll for the coin
months and then twice and three times
right so many stages to it if you want
to work out the number of outcomes for a
multi stage of it it's a bit more
complicated than just counting them up
right so for example if you roll a die
and flip a coin okay one of the simplest
things you can do whenever you have a
probability question is if it's small
enough just list them out if it's small
enough just list them out how many ways
are there to flip a coin to there are
only two heads or tails I'm going to
draw something which I hope you will
remember from a couple of years ago and
those of you who yesterday will recall
this is called a tree diagram because
these are going to branch off and show
me all my different outcomes now you're
probably not going to have to draw many
more than these practically how many
branches going to be on the end after
you get the heads there's going to be
the die right so how many outcomes over
there are six for this one and then
there are another six for this one so
let's just quickly drawn
so and I heard it just mentioned right
there are 12 and that's easy to count
but I didn't need to we didn't need to
draw that diagram to know that there
were 12 how could we have counter the
outcomes right from the utter without
having to resort to draw your diagram or
guess just multiplication that's all
these right if you want to work out the
number of total outcomes over here which
there are 12 all you need to do is go if
you roll a diet flip a coin there's six
ways to roll the die and there are two
ways to flip a coin right so therefore
there are six times two which as we just
said is 12 12 total outcomes and you
could use the tree diagram to service
them out head 1head 2head 3head cetera
et cetera okay now as you can imagine
this becomes more and more useful the
more outcomes they are and the more
stages there are she's got like five
stages you don't want to have to draw
that tree diagram you're going to be
dead for the sunsets ok so therefore we
can use this kind of little shortcut
here to find out how many outcomes there
are for any multistage of it ok and
there's one other idea i want to show
you but i'm going to let you get started
on using this first anytime you want to
work out this total number you just got
to think about each of the stages and
how many ways you can do each of those
dangerous ok